very you're very fun to look at and
you're very good at just like
nailing it um so i'll just say
everything and you can cut out anything
that you
don't want i'll just be as authentic
yeah i just think i just think it would
be good to have a talk
about helping people because it's not as
simple as like
i think a lot of people see my videos
and they see they say caroline who we
just spoke to or we
see oh it's an endless list of people
that come
in here oh my god they just need this
then the other don't you help them
and i'm sure we could probably shed a
little light on
what helping these people is actually
like sure that's what you do
right yeah so i mean since the first
video
you and i have tried to help a number of
people
i always try to basically have interface
with someone so if mark or anyone else
says to me i have someone who really
needs support i want to sit down with
them
and i want to hear from them directly i
prefer if they're not
high but i understand sometimes
that's unavoidable especially when it
comes to things like crack because then
it's really challenging
because crack does so much to your
psyche crack is harder to deal with than
heroin or in my experience i'm not a
doctor but in my experience
because of like this psychosis may not
be the correct term but because of what
happens to someone when they're high on
crack the visions the
voices it's really challenging to even
get to the core of
a person i mean they're all they're all
terrible drugs and they're all they're
all awful
but in terms of interfacing to find out
if someone is ready for treatment and if
they really want this
it's more challenging with meth and
crack than it is some of the other
drugs for me anyway maybe that's i don't
know why would that would be but that's
how it's been because i can't get to a
person
so um since the first video you've
brought a number of people to me
if they show up for the meeting like we
just had one and they left in the middle
of it um
because they were hallucinating or what
did you say
no i think i think i'm good we were in
the middle of talking about what
treatment looks like and what her dreams
would be
moving forward and she just said i'm
good and left
yeah no and and just to add there have
been a couple even more than a couple
people that i've tried to help in a
serious way like
because what you're offering is
basically housing and education
job training therapy rehab the whole
thing on a silver platter all you gotta
do is
show up yeah and we've had a couple
people there a couple teenage
people that everyone was screaming at oh
my god why don't you help these people
so we lined it all up with you with your
organization
patrick katie and uh yeah
i don't want to name names but if you
watch my channel you'll figure out who
i'm talking about
so we we arranged an appointment for
that person to show up with you and me
and
and we're going to lay it all out for
how we're going to
save your life yeah we don't say it that
way we just like
you know would you like rehab would you
like housing would you like an education
would you like some job training would
you like some therapy
they say yes and they fail to show up
for the appointment
yeah and then we give them a second
chance yes always
and again they fail to show up yeah so
ultimately it becomes more about
getting them to accept being
being fulfilled and happy in life which
which is the biggest hurdle
it's it's really challenging and i don't
fault the people that don't show up and
i don't
have any frustration toward them i just
think it's important to give context and
that context is these people have gone
their entire lives most of them
being abused and being told that they
are nothing so
even if they are presented with an
opportunity that you want to give them
or that patrick katie wants to give them
or is it aurora aura or
that aura wants to give them it's it
seems so
unreal that i think it just
it's like some sort of fantasy alternate
reality to where they are
and they deserve the help but the mental
health aspect is what we don't
really have a grasp on and what brings
someone to the streets a lot of time and
what brings someone to drugs
is where they're at mentally and the
abuse and the mistreatment that's taken
place
so it's like you think oh well here's
this
here's this opportunity that people
would just be running and lining up
but that doesn't even align with what
brings someone to
be in this place in the first place
right if things were that easy they
wouldn't
be here no it's yeah as i said i think
in the last norman video
it's not about drugs yeah drugs are not
the issue drugs are just
symptoms of the much much deeper and
more stubborn problem of
loving yourself and being able to accept
a better
life for yourself yeah which they can't
and and
and how do you fix somebody's childhood
i don't even know
it's like even the people that i do get
through to that we do work with
they even after they've been sober for a
year or two
it doesn't go away and if anything it
gets louder so kind of like i talked
about before it's
it's it's such a large hurdle
and it's so unbelievable to most people
that someone would come in out of
nowhere
and make us a real effort to just give
them more opportunity when they've been
taught over and over for decades that
they don't deserve those opportunities
so it's just i mean even when we posted
the last video
i got a number of inquiries through
patrick katie foundation website
and i didn't get a single person that
actually followed up with me i emailed
everybody back i said
set a time to have a call with me let's
discuss whether it be them or their
child or whatever i did have one mom
that did respond to me that was saying
that explained her daughter's situation
and i said okay i just need your
daughter
to call me because i'm not gonna get
somebody through treatment if i can't
talk to them first there's no world
where i can even be of support or anyone
else in our foundation can do anything
if the person isn't willing to have a
conversation her daughter never called
me
and it's not anyone's fault but
it's so deeply ingrained in people
that end up in these situations
and it's it's such a it's again it's
such a large hurdle
and there's we have to have such
patience
like for what you do i see you give
money to people all the time
it takes such patience to not get
frustrated or lose hope because
all that we want at the foundation all
that i want as a human being
is to take care of other people and help
other people
and when nobody will show up and meet me
or if they meet me and they walk out
it's like oh [ __ ]
like how do i help um and i think that
that's what you're doing
here is awareness awareness is how we
help because it's a concerted effort i
mean i do
more than my share of health you do lot
and i try not to show that because i
don't want this to be a help channel
this is not a this is this
this channel i'm doing is not about oh
let's help this person let's help
caroline let's help
whoever you name your person um it's
about creating awareness so that we can
prevent this because i see that as the
real solution
because i don't think we can patch all
these people no
the the there are thousands of people
here and just on skid row and there are
other communities like this all across
the country and in every viewer's
hometown i guarantee you
there are people just like this so you
don't need to like travel across the
country and
fix caroline you need to just if you
want to help these people
figure out somebody right in your
backyard that's doing it yeah doing
doing the same
damage to themselves but the purpose of
this channel is not about helping
caroline right the purpose of this
channel is to show you how
keeping families intact and together and
and supporting
communities that are
reach you know just churning over
generation after generation after
generation of these
uneducated damaged people from broken
families
that's gonna be the solution because i
don't think we can fix caroline or
or i mean you know a lot of these people
that we're gonna let's say we did help
let's say we got them rehab we got them
in education we got them some job
training we got them some therapy
they still have a long long list of
problems like the inability to trust
others
the inability to create trust from
others the inability to
to handle money they see money they burn
it
it's what they do they don't understand
savings doesn't know
no one's taught them to save money they
don't understand postponed gratification
they don't understand
anything you need to do to fulfill your
love to be functional and have a
you know happy life yeah
that's why i think prevention is the
answer and that's the purpose of this
channel it's not about fixing these
people because i don't know
that you me and 150 000
other people could actually help
caroline
yeah or whoever who just walked out of
here yeah um
it's such a big problem and it's so
difficult to
help each and every one of these people
the purpose again i'm saying it for the
400th time
is let's see what's broken about our
society so this doesn't happen
because it's going to happen again and
again and it's going to grow and it's
it's already growing look around your
town
right i know ever since ever since covid
downtown and skid row has
just grown exponentially well it's not
even about covet cove is a whole other
problem that makes it worse but
but it's just growing and growing this
is growing rapidly for the last
10 20 years and i'm sure it's going to
continue unless we do some things to
address
what's causing it and for us as a as a
non-profit
we do intend to help but it's just
important that people understand what
help really looks like and who is
actually willing to receive that help
because
it's proven to be exceptionally
challenging to find
people that even want the
help that's right that's it right there
nobody really they say they want it on
video i mean there's
there have been a couple people that sat
where you're sitting and said
i just wish somebody would help me right
and your eyes start watering and your
heart opens up
and you want to help them and when when
the rubber hits the road they actually
don't want the help right they can't
accept it it's not it's not
and the answer is not to oh just well
screw them and forget about them
right because i believe i'm not
religious but i believe you need to be
like jesus and just keep giving him a
chance keep giving him a chance
even when they screw up for the 15th
time
you keep giving him a chance that's
patience that's what you need
and it requires so much and i can't do
it for all of the 2 000 people plus that
i've interviewed right
and there's there's 12 000 more that i
haven't interviewed they're all
surrounding me here
yeah it's just it's just too much for
one person and if you guys all want to
fly out to la and fix everybody on skid
row come on out but there's people in
your hometown
in new jersey or philadelphia or miami
or
chicago wherever that that are in the
same exact situation so
you don't need to come here this is not
just a
an odd situation that happens in la this
is happening all across the country and
probably
all over the world yeah yeah it really
is
and it's it really just boils down to
awareness and the willingness to be
patient
and the willingness to understand the
human condition enough
to love these people outside of what
you're seeing on your youtube
channel you know what i'm saying like
somebody taught them that that's what
they were worth so
again it goes back to how we're treating
these children
how we're keeping these families what
we're doing systemically to support
people who need support
that's where we actually break this
cycle and as far as the people who were
already here
we'll do everything we can but it's hard
yeah i had lunch with you a month ago
and you said one of the most interesting
things i've ever heard
which i can't stop thinking about which
is
like what because it's it's a
recycling you know multi-generational
problem it keeps every family keeps
doing the same thing to
their own and they it just goes on and
on like when did this start did it get
worse and you said
no this is how the country was built i'm
paraphrasing but
you said something like this is how the
united states was created a bunch of
europeans came here
raped and stole from the indians and
that generation did it to the following
you know it just continued on and it
looks different every 100 years it looks
different so now it's about homelessness
and drugs
and all that kind of stuff but 100 years
ago it was it looked very different but
it was all the same problem
it was all the same problem and and
things were just more separate
yeah with the internet and everything
else we're getting exposed to things
that have been existing
for the entirety of this country's
history
but before it was hidden away in the
projects or wherever it was and
other people people like us that are
privileged didn't see it
but it is we this country started out
with a violent with a violent um
intent it was built on violence it was
built on violence
so to unlearn that we have to figure out
how to have more of a sense of community
and that comes in at all angles not
everybody should be helping
not everybody should be doing something
we just have to figure this out and like
you said be like jesus
and have some patience and understanding
for people
yeah it's it's it's a huge problem it's
growing
and patching the broken ones is not the
answer that's a that's a simplistic
product yeah i think you have to think
much bigger
which is the purpose of my channel let's
let's look at what's wrong what's wrong
what's broken
so that we can start figuring out how to
solve it because i don't even know
if doing things to keep families
together would you even work or be the
total solution because then there's
still the lack of hope
in these communities the lack of
like it's so it runs so deep and it's so
complicated and systemic
that it's it seems impossible
at times but if we
all start to have the same conversations
it becomes more and more possible
exactly i think you can say it's about
the family you can say it's about the
lack of education or
the lack of opportunities in the in the
some of the communities that these
people grow in
grow up into but
ultimately i hate to be one of these
people but it's like it's ultimately
about
love yeah and if blueish are called ever
wants their name back
yeah i would change the name to
unconditional love because that's really
what it's all about that's what we're
missing we're divided by politics we're
divided by race we're divided by all
these things that
aren't doing us any good we have to
learn how to fall back in love with
ourselves and with our
each other and with the community that
we're a part of because we have to take
care of this world we only get one
and that's it so you and i will keep
doing our part
and everybody can do something no matter
how small it is
by the person behind you when you're at
walmart buy their stuff
you know if it's a mom with three kids
and you can tell she's struggling and
you're okay just buy it just do
something to give other people hope
beautifully said monica you're amazing
thank you
thank you so much thank you this is just
an impromptu thing we were trying to
we were trying to meet caroline to help
her get on in one of your programs and
she turned on her heels and ran away and
it's okay
because if she decides she wants it
again i'll meet with her again yeah no i
love carolina she's the great
she's my original like the first friend
i really made down here and
i've known her for 10 or 11 years and it
breaks my heart every time i see her out
there trying to pick up some guy who's
just gonna
yeah that's hard give her 30 bucks for
some crazy act that she's going to do
and i know
and it's just so sad but you're doing
your part
yeah you're amazing thank you so much